i don't even remember when i got that
realization because i think i must have
got it
when i properly started getting into
anime with naruto was my first like
anime anime
um and that was purely because i just
kept seeing
avatars and you know gifts on the
internet and i was like yeah
this kind of looks like dragon ball z
which i grew up on which is that cartoon
that
i was really into do they have
ridiculously spiky hair yeah
probably the same thing exactly right
yeah i think because i was on the
internet way before i started watching
anime and i think
obviously being on the internet you see
a lot of anime i was just thinking
like what is this [ __ ] like what
what i'm just trying to play runescape
why am i talking about this
i don't get it all i knew is that their
opinion didn't matter because they had
profile anime profile pictures which i
guess
still is like it's a timeless thing
now that it's just it's generational now
it's generational oh man i
i mean pokemon was the first one for me
i must have been like god
i mean pokemon was always one of my
favorite shows i think we've mentioned
this
in like episode zero or something that
it had like an overarching story
yeah which you only really got you
didn't really get it actually in any
except for like avatar but that came way
later
yeah like an old like 90s do you just
call avatar and anime
or like cartoons sorry i was comparing a
cartoon i was about to [ __ ]
because like you know you don't watch
courage the cowardly dog for the
overarching story
right like you watch it because it's
like every episode's great and you have
a good time but then i remember pokemon
was like oh wow they're like actually
like working towards something
yeah i think as well like that era of
anime as well like unlike a lot of
cartoons
it was like yes there was like episodic
moments
but as you said there was like an
overall yeah you even if it was a filler
you knew they were like they had a goal
yeah yeah yeah yeah and and that seemed
to be the case where that kind of
structure
really like spoke to me as if for
whatever reason i really enjoyed that as
a kid and then yeah yugioh had the same
thing
and then i thought oh well all these
things with all the spiky had people and
they're really like well-drawn things
they're like i like these kind of things
it's so weird though for me at least
with yu-gi-oh
yeah is that i didn't know yu-gi-oh was
an anime
because i grew up with the card game
first three yeah yeah yeah same time i
got the card game and then watched that
yeah right
because everyone in your school was
playing yugioh yeah i didn't get that
phase i didn't go
i didn't get that yukio phase we had i
because when i was in school everyone
was like trading pokemon cards
and nobody knew how to play the actual
game no no no no
no no no one did we had like a black
market like trade deal with pokemon
cards
i had like i had like a really dark like
yugioh face cause like
i was like i was legit like [ __ ] my
dad
because my dad like used to work for
like a printing company yeah so what he
would do is he would find like high-res
like pictures of exodus oh no no
no my parents were anywhere anywhere
like print them out and i would come to
school and i'd be like yeah i got all my
pieces of exodus
and i'd be like a ten-year-old doesn't
know right so like
whoa no way you got exotic but it was
funny as well because like much like
your pokemon cards
no one knew how to play yu-gi-oh it was
just like oh cool you have exodia
because i feel like the
um the rules of hugo were easier to
understand oh yeah
then rules of pokemon yeah pokemon's
hard yeah because i did like i
don't think anyone in my school played
the pokemon card game you should collect
them yeah you just you just collected
them right you had like it was easy to
understand you had a shiny
um charizard well that's the thing
though right it's like
in order to play the pokemon card games
you needed to like not throw away the
energy cards
like my my school like um
in my school everyone was just like yep
got
got got i haven't got now that was just
that was just lunch time
every day at my school yeah um but yeah
because i've
i started to realize that i really liked
anime when
everyone got into pokemon when we had
the pokemon card card game phase as well
so it was just like a global craze
oh yeah then how long did that last that
lasted like a year or something right
well i think or like a few months the
year i was born 1996 i think
pokemon was the most googled thing yeah
of that year well because the game it
just
it just came out and obviously since
that point onwards it's pretty through
the mid 2000s it's
pretty insane pokemon was like and
arguably still today is one of the
biggest like